When President Trump announced his plans
to move the U.S. embassy from Tel Aviv
to Jerusalem, "It is time to officially
recognize Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel." he reversed decades of consensus
about the status of Jerusalem. The
announcement sparked massive protests
among Palestinians and throughout the
Muslim world. Here are five things to
know about Jerusalem and why it's so contentious.
Israel has controlled West
Jerusalem since 1949. During the Six-Day
War Israel captured East Jerusalem and
annexed that half of the city, but the
international community considers East
Jerusalem occupied territory. In 1980
after Israel passed a law declaring a
united Jerusalem their capital, the
United Nations condemned the annexation.
Palestinians want to divide the city and
make East Jerusalem the capital of a
future Palestinian state, while Israelis
want a unified Jerusalem to be their
capital.
During peace process negotiations for the Oslo Accords, the issue of Jerusalem was initially set
aside to avoid derailing the talks. In
2000, during a new round of negotiations,
talks were upended when the leaders of
Palestine and Israel disputed who would
control the maze of tunnels under
Jerusalem.
Control of Jerusalem has been a trigger
for violence many times in the past. The
contested area of East Jerusalem is home
to some of the holiest sites in the
world
for Jews and Muslims. It is the site
where Judaism's two sacred temples once
stood and the site where the Prophet
Mohammed ascended to heaven. The trouble
is that the sites for Muslims and Jews
exist on the same land. There's a
precarious power share in place: Israeli
officials control who has access to the
complex, but Muslims have religious
control inside.
Jews can enter but, aren't allowed to
pray. Instead, they use the Western Wall.
The Second Intifada began in 2000 when
then-opposition leader Ariel Sharon
visited the Temple Mount, to assert
Israel's right to the complex.
Palestinians protested and were met with
tear gas and rubber bullets. The violence
lasted five years and killed over 3,000
Palestinians and nearly 1,000 Israelis,
with thousands more wounded.
More recently, Israel set up metal
detectors to enter the complex, which
Palestinians say restricted access to
the holy site, sparking a new round of
protests and violence.
In the early '70s sixteen countries had
embassies including the Netherlands,
Costa Rica, Colombia, but after the UN
Security Council condemned the
annexation of East Jerusalem in 1980,
member states left. Now Jerusalem only
has consulates - the U.S. would be the first
country to have an embassy back in the
city.
Though Congress passed a law to
relocate the U.S. embassy to Jerusalem
more than 20 years ago, the law includes
a loophole that allows the president to
delay the relocation for the sake of
national security.
Every sitting president, Clinton, Bush,
Obama, has used this power and signed the
waiver every six months. President Trump
signed the waiver in June 2017 and again
in December 2017, but also signaled he
would begin the process of moving the
embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem.
President Trump was careful not to call
Jerusalem the undivided capital of
Israel, but opposition to Trump's
declarations and the proposed embassy
move grows. Muslim countries worldwide
urge the recognition of East Jerusalem
as the capital of a future Palestinian
state. In Jerusalem, tensions are higher
than usual. Palestinian militant group
Hamas has started launching rockets into
Israel from Gaza and calling for a third
Intifada.
Israel has arrested Palestinians and is
clamping down on protests and as lines
are drawn and the fight for Jerusalem
intensifies, the future of
israeli-palestinian stability is once
again at risk.